Honeypots is another component of
the intrusion detection technologies.
Honeypots are decoy systems
to attract the attackers away
from the critical systems.
By diverting attackers from valuable
systems to honeypots, we can observe
what the attackers are trying to
do to our systems and networks.
And based on that information,
we can develop strategies
to respond to the attacks.
Typically a honeypot system is
filled with fabricated information
to make it appear to be
a valuable system on the network.
A honeypot system is instrumented
with monitors and event loggers so
that any access, or any activity
on the honeypot system is logged.
In order to attract attackers to
a honeypot and keep them there, so
that we can gather more
information about attacks.
Any attack against a honeypot
is made to seem successful.
Most importantly, a honeypot is not
a real system used by any real user.
Therefore any access to
honeypot is not legitimate.
Most likely, any inbound connection
to honeypot is a network scan or
direct attack.
In addition,
any outbound traffic from the honey pot
means that they system is
most likely compromised.